there are ways by which Humanity can
behave better and one of them is right
now we are allocating $2 trillion do a
year to military budgets and if we just
listen to John lenon who said imagine
all the people living in peace and
instead of relying on John lenon you
know I can imagine this message coming
from outside from a more intelligent
species that is not wasting resources on
fighting each other on a surface of a
rock that they happen to be born on so
if we realize that it makes more sense
for us to work together and avoid
conflicts then we will have a surplus of
$2 trillion doll a year that we can use
to send a probe to every star in the
Milky Way galaxy within this century